It's so crazy that you're expected to
like not make fun of these people.
Anyone who watches our podcast has to be
brain dead. It's just desperate. Like
the fact Ethan would lower himself to
Diorio is desperate. I don't really care
if it's true or not. I care that he
handled it terribly. This clip is really
embarrassing for him. What are you
afraid? You afraid to show your putrid
malformed chins? So, recently Anisa Joma
has been snarking epic style on Nicholas
Deorio,
uh who obviously people around here are
not not a huge fans of to say the least.
That's been quite funny to see. Now it
appears there is a bit of a chain
reaction happening, a bit of a domino
effect.
The dam is breaking because Adam
McIntyre here, who is
a total rat,
but I have agreed with him occasionally,
but he's just released a video
called Nicholas Deorio is a loser. So as
we know, okay guys, support for
Adam McIntyre is pivotal right now.
We're going to take a look. We're going
to see. I assume this is
off the back of the Anisa stuff. Let's
see. Okay everyone, let's talk about
>> It looks like it's a stream segment.
Nicholas Deorio. Now Nicholas Deorio is
someone that I have wanted to talk about
for a while, but he's just never been
involved in something that has been like
so popular that like people know about
him. Like anytime I've tried to talk
about him in the past, like you guys
have been like, "Who is this? Like who
the is Nicholas Deorio?" Um but I think
this time I want to talk about him
because he has been non-stop making
videos and tweeting about me and all of
the rest. And the reason for that is
because Nicholas Deorio is a drama
channel who used to be like in the
Keemstar world of it all, but recently
has became an Ethan Klein
bootlicker. So if you guys are aware, we
watched a video recently of a Ela Klein
impression where it was like, "I love
Nicholas Deorio."
Like uh he he does good
>> That's yeah. That's all the Anisa stuff
that we
We've already covered that I just
mentioned. search like whatever the
[__] right?
He became basically a
a [__] doormat for the H3 people. So
it's so funny is he used to make these
videos that would be like really calling
people out and like actually for a lot
of times as well would kind of, you
know,
he would be the person who would be like
exposing something and he would always
go against like what the the people
wanted him to do. Like he would go
against the grain, if you will. But it's
so funny because Ethan started giving
him attention and then he started to
really lap it up like a little dog. And
so all of his content that he makes now
will be people that Ethan Klein doesn't
like. Yeah, it
I think what from Adam McIntyre's
perspective, I think it probably seems
like Nicholas Deorio is going against
the grain cuz Nicholas Deorio is
probably on the other side of a lot of
dramas that Adam McIntyre
knows about and cares about. And all of
his friends are probably on the same
side of that drama as him.
Whereas in Nick Deorio's world around
him, he's actually going totally with
the grain or pretty much all the time.
So he makes videos on me, he makes
videos on, you know, Ian, iDubbbz, he
makes videos on basically every single
person that Ethan will talk about on the
show.
So if I go through his channel right
here. Look at this. 9 hours ago, a video
on me. Adam McIntyre's crybaby meltdown.
Um he will always make videos defending
AB. He will always make videos against
Ian and Anisa.
I Ethan Klein is sick of iDubbbz's
[__] Like he will Listen, look at
this. He's always against iDubbbz. He's
done like a little puppet a little
puppet to basic Ethan Klein annihilated
this person. You know what I mean? Like
it's all this like it's so cringey. Like
he became the biggest satellite and the
biggest little doormat [__] for Ethan
because again, all people like Nicholas
Deorio want is attention. And you know,
whenever they didn't get, you know,
attention or love or appreciation from
their peers for whatever reason
>> I mean he's got you know, I'm not going
to This is kind of facts. This is kind
of facts, especially about Deorio.
>> that validation, they really cling on to
it. And so Nicholas is like that with
Ethan and Ela. You know, he finally
feels a part of something. He finally
feels wanted. And again, for whatever
reason
>> raiding them all now. That's why he's
like desperate raiding Guam and [__]
a lot of whatever the [__] his name is,
the Swedish guy and all this [__] and
AB. He wants to be part of it. He wants
to be part of He wants to be at the
Klein's pool party, guys. Send me the
Klein pool party thing. He wants to be
invited to the Klein family pool party.
He he's clearly someone who's not very
confident and he's clearly someone who's
not very sure of himself. So, you know,
having this community now like want to
watch his videos or defend him because
he's willing to, you know,
basically be a lapdog
>> there was a Klein family pool party
where all the
I think like all the H3 crew are
invited. There was like Harley was
there. I think Guam was there and all
these people.
Ethan and Ela must be really validating
for him. Must be really validating for
him because he wasn't getting it
anywhere else. But anyways, this video
has been sent to me non-stop. Uh this
going to be Did Nicholas Deorio add you
to the drama group chat a couple years
ago?
>> only posted like some video from on
Twitter. He posted a video of like Ethan
in the pool and his shirt.
Yeah, I was in a group chat a couple
years ago with like Zylbrad, Keemstar,
Nicholas Deorio and stuff. And that was
because I was added to it. Paige
Christie was in it as well. We didn't
want to be a part of it. We didn't write
in it. We were just added to it. And
yeah, it was like Nicholas and Keemstar.
And even in that, in fairness, they were
all basically telling each other what
videos to make because these people are
just [__] like they they really just
want someone to tell them what to do.
And again, Nicholas finally has that
sense of direction that he's clearly
been Yeah, so this is the post.
It's got a lot to see. You can't really
make out the tattoo.
Where is it? Where is Ethan?
Where is Ethan? Right? That's Ethan in
the shot there.
You can see the [__] healer tattoo,
dude. Look, you can see the [__]
healer tattoo on his arm, right?
Right there, the [__] healer tattoo.
Dude,
it's so crazy that you're expected to
like not make fun of these people.
You're expected to like not make fun of
these people and not treat them poorly
and be like, "Wow, you're like a
deranged [__]
embarrassing retard."
You're like uh this is like
really embarrassing and the tattoo
you've got of your wife looks like a
slasher movie villain.
And she talks like a [__]
You're supposed to not say that. You're
supposed to not say that. You're
supposed to say, "Anyone who says that
should be sued. Anyone who says that
should be should They should have their
Reddit account banned and they should be
force DMCA'd and they should be sued and
they should be forced to apologize
uh forever besmirching the good name of
Asmongold."
missing in his life from people like
Ethan and Ela and I. So let's get to
this video. It is from
this YouTuber right here.
Schleepy? Schleepy? And it's Let's go.
Let's [__] go. All right, guy.
It's called Nicholas Deorio is a total
loser. And I've been waiting to watch
this and you guys have been tagged me in
this. So let's get to it and again,
shout out to this creator. Something's
been bothering me lately and I just
can't shake it. Last week we talked
about H3 H3 and them taking offense to
Anisa's impression of Ela Klein. And
while they were offended, somebody else
decided to be offended on their behalf.
I'm a big fan of Nicholas Deorio. What
Oh my god. Yes.
Nicholas did a stream where he was so
defensive of Ela and this impression. He
was so upset for her. Oh my god, he's
such a little [__] Can I say you do
your research?
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. I know. Not only is that
offensive, it's also bad. Like it's
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Oh my god.
Not only is it offensive, it's just bad.
A bad impression. The ultimate review
guy thought that impersonating Ela Klein
was a bridge too far. That's a little
offensive. By the way, the wiggler that
he uses as his little persona because
God forbid he shows his face on camera
when he decides to [__] talk someone.
That character is actively wearing an
ultimate review helmet as he's saying
that an impression is offensive. And I
mean, when I saw Anisa's clip, the first
thing that I thought of was not, "What
is H3 H3 going to say about this?"
Obviously they're going to find it
offensive. What I was thinking was,
"Huh, how is Nick Deorio going to avoid
covering this?" Because I had no
expectation that this guy who has a
massive background in the commentary
community before becoming a shill for
the Kleins
>> Yeah. would openly say on his stream
>> on camera 2 seconds ago. It doesn't
count. Doesn't count. Doesn't count.
going XQC and you're like, "Hey dude,
what are you going TO COVER TODAY?"
IT'S SO FUNNY LIKE ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO
[__] sell their [__] holes, all
right, like Nicholas. You know, you can
always find a clip of them being
contradictory in something that they're
now doing.
>> what are you expecting [__] XQC to
say about JFK's assassination?
As someone who grew up in Quebec, I
found that deeply
>> can't remember what dramas I've had with
Anisa with Adam McIntyre, but I know
I've watched Adam McIntyre dramas. I
thought he was he was being like kind of
a rat. So I I just I just know that to
be the case. Colleen Ballinger, his
whole thing he blew up on, he did
totally fudge the Colleen Ballinger
[__]
Okay, what the [__] Nick? You [__]
[__] How dare you go after XQC?
Don't you know it's his second language?
Sorry guys, I forgot. The only people
you're not allowed to criticize are
Israelis apparently. How dare you do an
impression of a self-proclaimed IDF
soldier who volunteered to go on to a
night raid into a terrorist city, as
Ethan Klein would say. So I was a
soldier. You told me what you wanted to
>> even just that he milked it. It's like,
you know, he was like obviously blowing
stuff like way out of proportion. He
didn't actually think Colleen Ballinger
was trying to [__] groom him.
Or [__] he was act he would act like,
you know,
that was that was like undeniably the
case. So like
Yeah, he was like kind of obsessed. Like
some of the videos it's like he's
literally like pandering like [__]
crazy.
He's just like trying to kill her, you
know.
It's like I hate Colleen Ballinger. I
hate Colleen Ballinger. I hated her and
her things. And all the worst people I
knew growing up loved that [__] I've
every reason to want her gone
in the world.
And it was just like
but the the
the quality of her statement of how bad
the [__] she was doing is was insane.
And it's just one of those stupid like,
you know, TikTok [__] stories.
with them? Mhm. To like a terrorist
city? Yeah. That was kind of a crazy
story. Yeah, the So the my officers and
like the the soldiers in that brigade,
um they would go every night on a raid.
Right. In Ramallah to to arrest
terrorists. And um Arrest terrorists.
>> So I always saw them preparing for it in
the base.
>> Innocent civilians just living their
lives.
base. Mhm. So one [clears throat] time I
wanted to go with them just to
experience it. I just I just wanted to I
just wanted to know. I wanted to
experience raiding a terrorist city. I
mean, hell, she even looks like xQc in
this one. We can't make fun of both of
them? It got so bad that he even had to
release a statement on Augie RFC's
subreddit. Which by the way, between me
and you, Augie, I know how you feel
about this stuff.
>> what I was expecting. Maybe Diiorio's
been associating with the Kleins too
much, but he's starting to play their
tactics. In the clip I'm about to show
you, the H3 Podcast crew decide to spend
6 minutes trying to figure out if
smelling like pennies is an anti-Semitic
joke.
>> Tamara, she creeps me out for real. She
looks like she smells like pennies,
yeah. I am sorry, but what the [__] is
that? Well, I I that's what I wanted to
say. This is what I this is what I
wanted to talk about. I would cuz I
thought about that. And right away I was
like, "Whoa."
Really went in on the Jew [__] there.
>> god.
Insufferable.
In [__] sufferable.
Jesus Christ.
Why even risk being misconstrued as
anti-Semitic for nothing? These folks
>> Because you you literally call anything
anti-Semitic. misconstrue everything as
anti-Semitic Yes. all the time. That's
like half of the content on the podcast.
>> Literally. totally cool, totally kosher.
Apparently, going over Sneako's nudes,
laughing about it. How dare you say that
one of the crewmates on the podcast
smells like pennies. Oh, by the way,
we're going to laugh our asses off like
this.
>> [laughter]
>> THE PODCAST
LISTEN. [laughter]
WHAT IS going on with Sneako? What was
that? That was the gayest man alive.
What the hell was that?
What's going on with Sneako? That's the
gayest man alive. In response to his
nudes that were shared by Brandon
Buckingham being leaked. They can say
whatever the
>> [sighs]
>> It's so crazy just how
Anyone who watches that podcast has to
be brain dead. Like has to be brain dead
because you spend a majority of the
episode fake outraging over everything,
but then
you are going to spend a majority
>> Juice. That wouldn't surprise me if
that's what she mostly used. the
remaining time
basically being the most like hateful
[__] vindictive targeting
>> whoever the [__] they want, whenever
they want. But you dare say anything
that they can [__] that they will
interpret. Not anything that is
anti-Semitic, but anything they will
interpret
as anti-Semitic, which is going to be
everything, by the way. Which is going
to be literally everything. twist or
misconstrue in their own way, they will
twist it, and they will spend 6 minutes
telling you about it. And you know
what's crazy? She did this after in her
first stream, she had this story about
how Ethan and I show up late to the
podcast and then we leave right after,
so we have no soul. She said that we
have no soul.
>> pull that. I'll pull that. We got that.
But but people also pointed that that is
racist.
>> Yeah, the ultimate butt in the discord
is going for Cathy.
Like making people seem inhumane and and
less than.
>> I You show up late to your podcast, and
I don't think you put any soul into your
podcast. That's racist. It gets to a
point. Stop being a [__] crybully. I
genuinely think Diiorio has just spent
too much time watching their content and
supporting their ideas.
>> Kicking out
people. Maybe he's always just been like
this. Hey Nick, are you a crybully for
money, or is this all for the love of
the game? Nick Diiorio's entire content
strategy for the past year, his
thumbnails are [__] so stupid.
>> has been siding with Ethan Klein on
every possible situation and belittling
and [__] on anything. If they
[__] breathe wrong, belittling every
It really is crazy as well because he
really did completely [__] sell
himself out to just be Ethan's little
[__] lapdog. Everything. Everything.
It it's it it honestly, like as someone
who has been in this for many years and
seen him like go through different
phases and different people that he
would associate with, this one is
probably the funniest one because it's
like he must be so [__] embarrassed
of everything he [__] does. It he
truly must be.
>> It's mutual, I think. They're both
embarrassed of each other. And also, um
it just seems desperate. It's just
desperate. Like the fact Ethan would
lower himself to Diiorio is desperate.
everything that Ian and Anisa do. I
mean, I was watching this guy's VOD last
night, and he's talking about Anisa's
jewelry, how it's cheap and ugly. These
people get comfortable criticizing
people's relationships, talking about
how iDubbbz is a cuck in his
relationship, how Anisa's the one
wearing the pants. And it made me think,
I wonder I wonder about Nick Diiorio's
relationships. You know,
>> I saw a clip of this on Twitter. I've
been around a long time in this whole
commentary thing, and I remember I just
remember seeing a tweet, something that
Nick Diiorio posted.
>> But Taco, when did the tears come out of
my eyes? I was crying?
>> When did the tears come out of your
eyes? Probably when that girl said she
wasn't your girlfriend on that post.
That was the saddest [__] I've ever
seen. What girl said she wasn't my
girlfriend?
>> When you posted a picture of you holding
somebody's hand,
just trying to be vague about it, and
then they're like, "You have a
girlfriend?" And the girl's like, "No,
no, no, he's my best friend."
>> [laughter]
>> I have no idea what you're talking
about.
>> It's hilarious. No, that was funny as
[__] Okay, so that didn't happen, Nick.
Nick, did that happen or not? Yeah, it
absolutely happened.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh my god, he had posted a photo where
it was kind of insinuating that he was
like on a date or had a girlfriend, and
the girl responded and was like, "By the
way, this is not what you think it is."
>> You posted a vague picture of you
holding somebody's hand, God, it's so
funny. and then they're Do you have a
girlfriend? She's like, "No, no, no,
he's my best friend, and not my
girlfriend."
>> about my [__] personal life on here.
>> It's not your personal life. It's a
tweet you made. It's a tweet you made.
Oh my god. And then he [__] rage
baits. And then he [__] rage baits.
Oh my god, it's so funny, dude. It's so
funny. It's so funny.
Nick. I publicly Nick, it's a tweet you
made. That's not your personal life. Do
not [__] bring up my personal life.
>> It's not your personal life. It's a
tweet, not your personal life.
>> Oh, so good. Oh, whoa. You think it's
cool to talk about Make sure that donos
is taken out of the video. Thank you
gentleman for the $5. Huge appreciate.
Thanks so much. I I I intentionally
don't name people like this specifically
cuz I keep that part of my life very off
the internet. No, you don't. You tried
to post it and look cool, and you didn't
look cool. It was her idea to make the
[__] post in the first place. I told
her I was sure.
>> for real. Ooh, for real. Being friend
zoned publicly. She did. That's none of
your [__] business. Then why'd you
post it on Twitter, Nick? belong in this
argument.
>> of my business. Why is it up there,
Nick? Yeah, like they It's just so
crazy. And also, Nick claims he debunked
this. I've seen this debunked. I think
we've seen it before on stream.
We've seen this debunked, but uh it
misses out the fact
that he comes in and says, "Shh, women."
Like why is like they're saying just
friends, and he's coming in saying,
"Shh, women." It doesn't seem to make a
lot of sense his story.
Uh but hey, it could be the case he was
dating her,
you know.
I don't really care if it's true or not.
I care that he handled it terribly in
this clip. It's really embarrassing for
him.
What you guys have is looking at This is
so [__] funny. Oh my god. into
people's personal lives, and it's How is
this your personal life, Nick? Well, he
says it was it was it was his on-and-off
high school girlfriend.
That's what he says.
Hey, Taco.
>> BECAUSE IT'S FUNNY, REMEMBER?
>> [laughter]
>> AS IN SHE WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL, and he was
never in high school.
>> funny. Literally fighting for his life.
He's such a little pissy.
Oh my god.
>> It's about things that are funny. We're
debating. We're debating, Nick? Is that
what's happening?
Oh, DID NICK OH.
>> [laughter]
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHAT
>> HE LEFT.
>> BUT THEY'RE ALL LAUGHING ABOUT, and
Diiorio is getting extremely defensive
about, it's this tweet. Diiorio posts an
image of him clinking glasses with what
appears to be a woman. Someone replies,
"I guess you have a girlfriend." The
woman in question replies, "We
[laughter] aren't dating, but he's my
best friend." And Diiorio responds,
"Shh, women." Any man that has ever
lived, okay, any man that has ever
existed has been friend zoned, okay? Oh,
he was publicly friend zoned when he was
trying to insinuate that he had a
girlfriend.
Oh,
that is just
that that just sums up exactly how I
feel that his life is. Like it really
is. Dude, that happens. It's a part of
life. Yeah, Adam McIntyre the arch head
story. would not be criticizing or
making fun of somebody getting friend
zoned. But with Nicholas Deorio, there's
something cosmically beautiful about it.
>> Yeah, this guy the arch head story. That
arch head story needs to circulate more.
That one's actually true as well. And
he's lied about it so many times. It
he's lied about it.
And you can show the clips and you can
line it all up.
So, it's just perfect. It's just
perfect. It's brilliant.
makes most of his money by criticizing
and [__] on a couple that he just
does not like. Well, a couple that Ethan
Klein does not like. And frankly, it's a
couple that despite all of the It's in
one of my Deorio videos.
We got a lot of Deorio videos now.
That's what we love to say.
I think it's in there somewhere, right?
it in a different segment?
I don't know, man. It's in one of my
Deorio segments. It's in one of them
somewhere.
Basically, it was at a Turkey Tom party
and
he got bullied
by other YouTubers.
And lied about it.
It criticize
the hate online that they've had for
years has been able to stick together.
I'm not saying that they're a great
couple or a couple that I would model my
relationship after. Yeah, someone
someone stole his glasses off him
basically. Someone stole his glasses off
his face and was like making fun of him.
You got to give it to them. Despite all
of the hate, despite every single
commentary YouTube channel, including my
own, making fun of them, they have stuck
it out. And Deorio,
throughout this entire time, has been a
sad, lonely, single loser larping that
he has some sort of relationship on
Twitter and then getting called out in a
debate in a Discord call. Dude, you have
no idea what you're talking about. It's
hilarious. No, that was funny as [__]
Okay, so that didn't happen.
Nick, did that happen or not? Yeah, it
absolutely happened. You posted a vague
picture of you holding somebody's hand
or like [__] some [__] and then they
do you have a girlfriend? She's like,
"No, no, no, he's my best friend, he's
not my girlfriend." talk about my
[__] personal life on here. You know,
another question I asked was why don't
you show your face when you're [__]
talking people? You know, why don't you
why don't you put on a face cam, grab a
helmet that says ultimate rape review,
and and actually live the part a little
bit? You know, it takes a lot of the
oomph out of your bullying when you're
hiding behind a little wiggler. What are
you afraid? You afraid to show your
putrid malformed chins? Nick, you're a
[__] And you've gotten into one of the
best financial situations you could have
ever dreamt of, but all it cost was your
[__] soul.
>> Yeah, Logan should give Ela back her
meds. What meds were you talking about
there? A horse dewormer? Remember when
you and the boys were calling her a
horse faced [__] Did you switch cuz
you found it offensive, Mr. Ultimate
Rape Review, or did you switch cuz the
money's so [__] good?
>> You call this just some charm? I have
the ugliest necklaces next to the
ugliest tattoos from the ugliest
personality.
Uh
Yo, where's your face cam, Nick?
Hey Nick, where's your face cam?
>> [laughter]
>> Nick likes to talk about materialistic
things. He's a big fan of watches. He's
criticizing Anissa's cheap necklace. I
also found out that he's got a pair of
$600 glasses. I found out about this cuz
he was talking about it in his story
from VidCon. Now, if you're not aware,
Nick Deorio has told this VidCon story a
couple of times, once on his stream,
then once on his podcast, and then a
second time on his stream. Now, when
Nick tells you this story, he wants you
to believe that some flamboyant gay man
confronted him over his coverage of
Bowblax. That this pipsqueak had some
funny sounding Some tiny flamboyant
nerdy gay dude just bullied him. I don't
know, it just
I just got one over on him.
voice. He's like, "I don't like you."
For the record, this is what Net Nobody
sounds like. All right, I want to start
off by saying that I'm neither a
capitalist nor am I not a capitalist. I
don't think Nick is very good at
impressions here. He's like, "I don't
like you." And I'm like, "Oh, okay."
[laughter] Like, "So wait, what do you
Who is this content for?
Adam's chatting love with Sleepy right
now. Wait wait until they hear him talk
about Indians. Wait until they hear him
talk about Indians. Now let's now let's
hear his
let's hear this guy's opinions on
immigration.
And he's like and then I
I
>> [laughter]
>> And then I just called him a slur.
I'm like, "You're acting like a slur
right now." You called him a slur. I
thought that that that would be
offensive, wouldn't it?
>> [laughter]
>> So, he snatched my glasses off my face
and started dancing seductively at me.
So, I followed him for like 2 seconds
and I realized he's not turning around
and then I walked back.
>> Now, if somebody takes glasses off your
face, what do you do about it? Would you
just call him a slur and let him walk
away with your glasses? Or you can go
get back your glasses. Oh, they're
prescription. You can have them back.
I'm like, "Yeah, thanks for my $600
glasses, asshole."
>> Yeah, but if you were if you were to go
like take my glasses or he did, he's
going to get smacked, bro. That's not my
fault, it's your fault.
>> [laughter]
>> You got to understand, I'm in like an
aura right now. Like the [__] Nick's
buddy Vega Right. Right.
He's in like an aura, guys. He was like
paralyzed. He was paralyzed. He just
couldn't believe what was going on. He
would have hit him.
He would have hit this guy.
But he just you know, he was paralyzed
to an aura. He just didn't know what was
going on.
He says that someone stole sunglasses,
but he wasn't going to run Hello guys,
he tells us well that he hit them with
his [__] low IQ behavior as well.
Like he would take them back. He would
just take the [__] glasses back.
If they if you felt like you could take
them back in the moment, that's what you
would do. That's what you should do.
Nick obviously felt like he couldn't
take them back. That's obviously the
case.
run to get them back because he just had
aura in that moment.
would smack someone to get his glasses
back. But Deorio himself, he'll let you
take his $600 glasses whenever you want.
You want to know why? Because Nick's a
short, fat, little man. That's why Nick
hides behind the wiggler. That's why his
girlfriend friend zoned him when he
posted a photo of their hands on
Twitter. And that's why when he was
bullying his autistic transgender friend
Bowblax, when Net Nobody decided
>> Don't forget he probably got bullied in
his frat in college, too. Never forget
that part. Never forget that part. We
can't prove it, but I but I'm so certain
it's the case. to come and take his $600
glasses off his face, he did absolutely
nothing. He's a sad, pathetic, little
man. Let me be clear, little little this
way, not not little this way.
That's the end of the video?
That being the end of the video is
crazy.
Oh my god.
First of all,
that video
was
so good. Huge Sleepy fans
>> The YouTuber is called Sleepy.
I've never seen this creator before,
but that was good. That was good. And a
a much smaller YouTuber,
12K.
>> Dude, I hate dude, literally, he says it
in the worst YouTuber YouTuber
YouTuber
Shut the [__] up, dude. Shut the [__]
up.
Nicholas Deorio is lying to you.
Ooh, I really want to watch this
channel's content.
Okay.
Sleepy is the YouTuber if you want to go
and support. But yeah, it it it's just
like
Nicholas Deorio to me is such a funny
person because like he really acts so
brave on Twitter and then you just kind
of like see him and you're like, "Oh my
god, you're like you're the person
you're the person in the movie." You
know, who like has such a terrible life.
Like no one wants to be their friend.
Like no one wants them. Like whatever
that like you get so evil online and
it's always like faceless and it's
always like anonymous. Like you're that
person in the movie. You know what I
mean? Like they you are a stereotype in
a movie. You really are.
I [__] love that [__]
tweet where he insinuates that he's out
with a girlfriend and someone goes, "Is
that your girlfriend?" And then she
responds and goes, "No, we're just
friends." Like
you can't make this [__] up.
You can't make this [__] up. Anyways,
Nicholas Deorio, mwah.
Mwah.
And guys, if you ever want to steal
something from him, just know that he'll
never try to get it back because he's
aura farming. He's aura farming. And
we'll leave it there. Watch this.
It's like slightly problematic inside
your own head, but it's not harming
anybody else other than yourself, right?
So, if it's like a lolicon depiction of
like an 8-year-old that's not harming
anyone?
No, I think that's on on like the
depiction rather than your consumption.
>> No, if it's not hurting anybody, what's
the difference between
What would you say the difference
between like a 16-year-old and like an
8-year-old?
You know, I'm not going anywhere near
this topic. I'm just I'm I'm I'm not
engaging I am not
trying to do that. I am saying that most
people have deep dark thoughts and most
people try to act kindly and do
otherwise. Like okay, so if you if you
disagree with that, I think you're
[__] lying. I So, I think there's a
difference.
He's such a weird guy.
I feel like Nick gets away with so much
cuz he's never on camera. You actually
his expressions and the way he's
behaving.
Dude, so many clips from this period are
so good. Where he's talking about that
where he's saying that story about how a
girl apparently put a finger up his ass.
By the way, based on timelines, I think
you can safely assume that's the same
girl who was
posting
the photo. So, you probably seen the
finger that he claims went in his ass.
Um
So, he when he tells that story about
the girl sticking the finger in his ass,
he does like this thing. He like it
looks like he like looks at the camera
and he's like
he should put the finger up there like
that like a like a total [__] weirdo.
And it's [__] brilliant. It's
hilarious It's like a great moment. It's
like, dude, what are we doing here? What
are we doing?
And he's doing the same [__] here. He's
doing like this
like
What are you doing? You're a [__]
weirdo, bro.
Try to act kindly and do otherwise. Like
if you disagree with that, I think
you're [__] lying. I So I think
there's a difference.
There's a difference between like these
whatever these deep dark like my deep
dark thoughts are like me watching like
these guys like throwing around like
dead body like organs and stuff. Like,
you know, that's like my thing. And mine
is watching the sexual tension between
Vaush and Destiny, right? Like Okay, I
have Yeah, that is very on scale.
sexualizing me without saying that you
like to [__] dogs. Okay. Oh Jesus
Christ.
What if we only like to [__] adolescent
dogs? Does that make you a pedophile
who's also into bestiality? Dude, I
didn't realize he was on panels with
Destiny back then.
This is not a Destiny appearance I hear
him reference.
I feel like he sort of
memory holes some of these.
like to [__] dogs. Okay. Oh Jesus
Christ.
whatever these deep dark like my deep
dark thoughts are like me watching like
these guys
This is like slightly problematic inside
your own head, but it's not harming
anybody else other than yourself, right?
So if it's like a lolicon depiction of
like an 8-year-old that's not harming
anyone?
No, I think that's on on like the
depiction rather than your consumption.
>> hurting anybody, what's the difference
between
What would you say the difference
between like a 16-year-old and like an
8-year-old?
You know, I'm not going anywhere near
this topic. So So in this conversation,
he's trying to just do internal critique
and like prove that her argument isn't
coherent.
But obviously he's kind of playing
a little stupid because he would act as
though
um
you know, he would be against
lolly of any description or just claim
to be anyway in almost any situation
where
Destiny isn't there.
But because Destiny is there, because
his father figure is there at the time
father figure at the time is there, he's
going to sit there and in this
circumstance he's not going to voice
that he has a big moral issue with lolly
because it might cause tension with with
his e-daddy.
And he does the same [__] with Ethan
now, bro. He does a very similar [__]
with Ethan and Ela. Very funny. Very
funny. Just more of the same pattern.
When Destiny joins, he gets so happy.
I'm just I'm I'm I'm not engaged I am
not trying to do that. I am saying that
most people have deep dark thoughts and
most people try to act kindly and do
otherwise. Like if you
if you disagree with that, I think
you're [__] lying. I So I think
there's a difference.
There's a difference between like these
whatever these deep dark like my deep
dark thoughts are like me watching like
these guys like throwing around like
dead body like organs and stuff. Like
And mine is The hands freak me out. The
hands are giving like rapey [__] you
know?
Of Mice and Men type-ish.
That's what it's giving me, bro.
Okay.